this is a CBS News special report I'm
Anthony Mason in New York the Labor
Department has just released its weekly
unemployment numbers the data show
massive job losses for a tenth straight
week since the pandemic began hitting
the economy CBS News business analyst
Jill Schlesinger joins us now Jill what
are the numbers this week an additional
2.1 americans filed for unemployment
benefits last week and that puts us up
at about 40 million americans over the
course of ten weeks now i should also
note that the Labor Department is
starting to also report on those folks
who are claiming the pandemic
unemployment assistance for contractors
and gig workers and that number is about
eight million so that's not even
included in the 40 million although
these numbers are trending lower these
are still disastrous numbers ten times
more than where we were before the
pandemic hit Anthony yeah a staggering
numbers still Jill even as they're
declining slightly wet industries if any
Jill are hiring at this point well we've
talked a lot about some of the
warehouses that are adding people and
the places like Amazon and Target and
Walmart but there is some evidence that
we're seeing demand for security guards
senior care workers people who are
online for bankers and mortgage brokers
landscapers and essential businesses
like defense contractors the problem is
that although this is a glimmer of hope
these folks are adding about say three
jobs for every ten layoffs that are
actually going on so we are still
running a huge deficit when it comes to
getting workers off the sidelines all
right Joe Schlessinger thanks you once
again 2.1 million Americans filing for
unemployment last week